what up space fam goes in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy developments in
the final attack on titan season
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
time videos and want to keep them coming
then the best thing you could do is show
attack on titan some love by warhammer
smashing that like button
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future attack on titan videos and while
you wait for the next insane episode to
drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on time playlist where we got
videos about all the titan shifters and
their powers all the acronyms and their
powers the titans rank for weak is the
strongest and much more link to that is
in the description
you can also check out our anime virgin
podcast where we discuss
anime with people who haven't seen them
before and we are currently
talking about attack on titan so check
it out you can relive this amazing
series with us
link to that is also in the description
now without further ado
let's jump into it this episode is
called deceivers and the deceivers can
refer to gabby and falco who are
deceiving those around them using fake
aliases and everything or to hanji and
the rest of the government who are
trying to keep the populace at large
in the dark about what is going on again
what we're pretty much
seeing is that there isn't a significant
difference between the aldians on the
island and the aldians from marley
except for their location of birth and
by extension their different upbringings
but onto the meat and potatoes as our
nuxi boy would say
this episode starts out with gabby
looking like she's going to die
in jail like she's having some sort of
deadly attack the poor guard is
concerned about her and rushes into the
cell to help the little girl
only to get lethally wrecked by a brick
blow to the head
as if we needed more reasons to hate
gabby it's a clear overkill
she just keeps going as falco mentions
the guy was worried about her and she
was merciless
islama has done such a great job of
making her unlikable
even as we should recognize that she is
in many ways the product of her
upbringing and is completely brainwashed
with marlene rhetoric
she's suffering from internalized racism
to the point where she hates aldeans
including herself
and projects that hate solely on the
aldians on the island
viewing them as the scapegoats and the
devils
however it's clear that even in her mind
there isn't a fundamental difference
between her and these island devils a
clear sign of this is that she hangs
onto the armband a symbol of her
brainware self and her subjugated status
it makes no sense logically for her to
keep wearing this armband it will only
give her away at this point and she
should despise it since it is a sign of
inequality however she freaks out when
falco takes it off
and by the way props to him for being
almost completely unbrainwashed by the
marlene propaganda
especially compared to gabby as gabby
says the reason she is so upset
is because with the armband she views
herself as a good aldian but without it
she is the same
as the devils this is very significant
despite her illogical
blinding hatred of the island devils she
psychologically knows there's only a
superficial difference between them one
that can boil down to simply wearing an
armband and following marlene
instruction it's easy to hate
gabby but we should keep in mind that
her hatefulness and despicable actions
are also an
outward projection of her self-hatred
too and the guilt and anxiety she
carries around
for being an eldian in her mind the more
she hates and kills the enemy
the more different she is from them but
that strategy has clearly not worked
very well
she is still incredibly insecure with
her own identity i mean you just need to
look at her expressions throughout this
episode to see how messed up she is
psychologically right up there with
crazy azula levels
avatar references aside her goal now is
not to escape the island alive but to
get answers from zeke before she's
caught and killed
it's a very interesting mission so much
of attack on titan focuses on
motivations on why characters behave the
way they do
and in this way attack on titan is
always about philosophy which philosophy
is right
which will win out and so on sometimes
this search for motivations and for the
truth is actually more important to
people than life itself
as we saw with erwin i will just quickly
add here that it was a bit weird for me
that there was only one dude guarding
them
and that they'd run into no one else
during their prison getaway
maybe because they were just kids but
this girl killed someone
if you're letting her live you gotta up
your security
one positive thing we can say about
gabby is that she does regret falco
coming along
and even cries saying he didn't have to
die she clearly cares about those close
to her
despite the fact that she's merciless to
her enemies when kaia spots them gabi is
actually prepared to kill her too
at this point you're probably extremely
upset with gabby especially since this
is the girl that sasha saved by holding
off a titan with nothing but a bow and
arrow after killing sasha
it looks like she'll kill the person she
saved as well
luckily gabby hits paws on her killing
spree when kai invites them over to eat
and now as it turns out
kaia is actually living with sasha's
parents along with plenty of other
orphaned children
this whole meeting is so crazy because
keep in mind sasha's parents are feeding
the girl that killed their daughter
gabby is so on edge she freaks out when
she gets patted on the head
she's so uncomfortable with these island
devils that she's been taught to hate
being nice to her her whole world view
is unraveling before her
eyes like reiner before her she's seeing
that these guys are just as human as the
people back home
and honestly these guys are probably way
nicer than the average people there
we then get a scene of kiyomi talking to
commander-in-chief
zachary the point here is that they are
developing relations and
she bought an airship that is powered by
iceberg stone
that very valuable resource on the
island the really interesting thing
though for me
is the public instability people are
upset that zeke has been
imprisoned and volunteers have been
detained not only that they're upset
that aaron opened up a path to victory
where every ldn can live and they put
him in jail for it
the news got out and people are
understandably not
happy since they didn't even have a say
in the matter this
is definitely no democracy reeves jr
actually makes a reappearance
hanji and he were on the same side
before when hanji actually revealed the
corruption in the past government by
printing the truth in the papers now
she's actually on the other side of the
government
keeping secrets from him and these other
people too
it's crazy to see obviously hanji is
doing her best and trying to figure out
what's their best approach
but now she's the one to keep people in
the dark and not letting them have a say
in big decisions she's become as the one
dude whose nails she ripped off
predicted
the system and she's seeing that it's
not easy being the system
important decisions have to be made like
what's best for the people and whether
the truth should be revealed
if doing so may hurt those very same
people and i really liked this about
attack on titan there wasn't just some
coup d'etat against the evil government
and the problem was solved
no after the coup you got a rule and
that ain't easy
even if you have good intentions and it
makes hanji look at the previous system
and previous officials
in a new light too but yeah hanji leaked
the truth in the past and this time
flocc leaked the truth against her will
and flocc makes some good points
he says that aaron wasn't in the wrong
because his actions led to a victory
that secures the rumbling which secures
the lives of the aliens hanji says that
there is no guarantee that the rumbling
plan
will work but flocc points out that this
is because they are keeping aaron and
zeke away from each other they'll never
know until they try
and as i said in the last review i gotta
empathize with this point of view
more than with hanji's even though i do
like her as a character and in her
defense she finally makes the decision
to carry out the jaeger plan
and she'll take responsibility for what
happens kanji still punishes flocc
but it seems like when she punished
aaron she doesn't necessarily think
they're in the wrong but as a leader
she's trying to maintain some sense of
authority and structure even if her
heart isn't really in it
she doesn't want the whole organization
to fall apart and descend into chaos
and she's clearly overwhelmed she's not
in this position because she wanted to
be she's just trying to do her best as
erwin wished she even admits that she's
pooped
a characteristically humorous word to
use for hanji but that makes it no less
true
then we have an interesting conversation
between mikasa and a survey corps member
she saved in the past but who has
now been arrested for leaking info about
aaron because that still has her scarf
that aaron gave her so it's not like
she's done with aaron after the stunt he
pulled in marley
however she has matured compared to
earlier on in the story the girl
suggests that mikasa could free aaron
but mikasa tells her to shut up
past mikasa might have tried to free
aaron but now
even though she cares about him it's no
longer just mikasan aaron vs the world
in mikasa's mind we saw when connie
straight up suggested the possibility of
having to kill aaron and mikasa didn't
go slit his throat immediately
for saying something like that and here
again she's valuing the opinion of hanji
and the others about keeping aaron in
jail rather than trying to break him out
it's noteworthy too that mikasa is
having these headaches as she gets
flashbacks of aaron saving her from the
kidnappers
all those years ago we realized that
flocc is the star eldian restorationist
as he helped yelana meet and plan with
aaron when he was escorting her and it's
noted that after jalna began seeing
aaron
that's when aaron began moving on his
own rather than following orders
it'll be interesting to see how floch
develops as the series ends but i think
you can understand where he's coming
from in the sense that he knows aaron
can help save the islanders so why not
help him do it let me know your thoughts
on flocc below
would you have done the same thing or
would you have respected hanji's
decision if you were in his shoes
we then jumped to a horse fighting
gaby's head which is pretty funny to see
she even blames this on the island
devils who are a scapegoat for pretty
much any issue she has
falco has a pretty chill plan they
should lay low here and just wait for
reiner and the rest to attack the island
at that point they can grab a ride back
after the conflict
falco is so stoic about this saying
there's nothing they can do about zeke
why worry about something outside of
their control but if falco's cool water
gabby is a raging fire she can't just
chill
if she even gets upset about being
called mia and being called his younger
sister this part
actually made me laugh how gabby gets
angry over practically
everything kai eventually comes and gets
them she explains that everyone here is
an orphan and that queen historia's
policies give support to orphans without
families i really like this detail
although a war is raging it's nice to
know that historia is still trying to
make the island a better place for
people living within it
and here we see why gabby would make the
worst imposter in among us
instead of playing it cool and showing
sympathy for the orphans who lost their
parents to titans
she says they haven't accepted their
guilt over the atrocities the people of
the island have committed
she says even if kaya acts like a saint
her sins are too great and
that's why her parents died this is how
messed up
and brainwashed gabby is she blames
innocent people for the tragedies that
happened in their lives
just because of what their ancestors
supposedly did
before they even arrive to this island
and kaya straight up asks
if that's what marlei teaches them this
is a great turn
and we're just lucky gabby didn't kill
her because she did try to
luckily falco interfered and saved kaya
kaya has all the reasons
in the world to call for help and admit
who these guys are
but she actually tells the others that
gabby just got jealous
because she thinks that kaia is stealing
her brother meaning falco
another hilarious moment that came out
of a very scary situation
where gabby almost killed another
innocent person
however kaia is building their trust at
this point since she helped them and
revealed she knew their secret but
didn't rat them out
she continues to help them she even goes
to a secluded place with them
which is just kind of crazy to me but
hey kaya is fearless now apparently kaia
talks about the girl meaning sasha who
saved her from a titan
she first watched as her mother was
being eaten alive
still probably one of the most creepy
and terrifying scenes
in all of attack on titan kaia can't
understand why the island aldians are
hated so much that people would actually
put them through something like this
gabby says it's because her kind
slaughtered people for thousands of
years but that applies to herself just
as much as tukaya the fact is kai and
her mother were born on the island
and had nothing to do with the eldians
who mistreated other cultures and people
i liked this conversation a lot and i
think hayah does a great job of showing
gabby that her logic doesn't make any
sense kaya actually gets more fired up
than gabby
during this exchange talking about her
mother's death and how she did nothing
wrong to deserve it
gabby is pretty much arguing probably
based on marlene teachings that eldians
must be punished for the sin of their
ancestors while kaya
is arguing that humans should be judged
on their own lives
and i think it's clear that kaya makes
way more sense the son shouldn't be
punished for the sins of the father
and he definitely shouldn't be punished
for the sins of his great great
grandfather what matters is what you do
with the life you're given
we aren't born into the world lesser or
more deserving of punishment than anyone
else
and that's what i think gabby is
starting to get although the
brainwashing has
clearly got quite the grip on her psyche
it's finally falco who apologizes saying
kaya's mother did nothing wrong
sometimes bad things happen to good
people it doesn't mean they deserved it
and here kaia says he doesn't need to
apologize
because he was just born in marley he's
not responsible for the actions of that
nation
just as kaya wants them to recognize her
as a human being not as a dehumanized
member of the enemy side
she is ready to return the favor despite
all the terrible things gabby says and
does
kaia still wants to help them and
invites them to a marlene restaurant
where they might be able to find a way
back home
and it's interesting to see how sasha
continues to live on even after her
death
in the form of kaya and everyone else
whose life she helped shape
what we do in life has ripple effects on
those around us
and even though sasha is dead her
willingness to risk her life and save
kaya led to kaya not only surviving but
becoming the kind of person who wants to
help others
it's crazy to think that sasha was
killed by gabby and that now kaya who
was saved by sasha
is helping gabby see that the ldns here
can be good and kind people
gabby has the girl she killed to thank
for her starting to break
through the mental chains that still
weigh her down this part
clearly shows that barriers can be
overcome with the help of kindness
bravery
empathy and time but people may die
before those barriers drop
that's the tragic part as is the fact
that they may take really long to drop
if they do at all we also get a part
near the end where marlei has realized
that zeke faked his death and they were
thinking about waiting six months to
attack with their allies but reiner is
like
he advises an immediate surprise attack
so we may see more action sooner than
expected for the preview it's called
guides
and we're asked who should one hate who
should one blame and there's mention of
a shifting truth
i love that term shifting truth and you
definitely get a lot of shifting truths
as you go through attack on titan in
this preview we also see a huge
explosion so there will definitely be
action the next episode but this one was
really good too
we didn't have titan fights but we had
important philosophical questions posed
and discussed
like whether we're born free and pure or
whether we're born
chained to the past needing to atone for
the sins of our ancestors there was
extremely important stuff about gabby
who it's easy to hate but we gotta keep
in mind she is brainwashed
af and she treats island aldian so
horribly in part because she is so
uncomfortable with her own status
as a devil aka as an aldian this in no
way makes her actions okay but it helps
explain why she acts the way she does
and i really think
kaya is helping her question her
ingrained biases
and long-held assumptions and how is she
doing this by simply being a good and
kind person to
her kaya is lucky that falco is there
though or she might have been dead
before she could show gabby
that not all island aldians are devils
but anyways that is it for this episode
review
let me know what you thought of it and
what you expect to see happening next i
loved seeing how sasha's actions during
her life continued to influence people
to this day who in turn influence others
and the world
so even if we aren't immortal this
reminds us that our actions and
treatment of others today
can have ripple effects into eternity a
powerful thought that i absolutely love
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
time videos and want to keep them coming
then the best thing you could do is
warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on
titan fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next insane episode to drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on time playlist where we got
videos about all the time shifters and
their powers all the acronyms and their
powers the titans rank for weak is the
strongest and much more
link to that is in the description you
can also check out our anime version
podcast where we discuss
anime with people who haven't seen them
before and we are currently talking
about attack on titan so check it out
you can relive the amazing series with
us
link to that is in the description as
well and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank
the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grotto the world acquire respect but
they have a liam thompson
al-jatal dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor taku
spidey life tinel baked buddhist and
tungsten tarkis and are pro hero to your
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kozlowski
joe stanton barry gucci jessica kayla
fond
rethuen de aura alicia actor bonnie
parks hinokami and water the red-haired
raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted note head deadly saint matthew
cruz and anthony schreiber
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work
you can support more of it by going over
to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime
life waifus and of course dank memes
so check out patreon.com upload link to
that is in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button
that you've hopefully already clicked so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer
whichever way you support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you